[Music]
Woo. I'm super excited to be here with
you. Um, this is my first time speaking
at AI engineer and um, we have an
amazing
um, group of speakers, guest speakers.
Vasilia Marovitz from Cogni. Vasilia um
oh there is Vasilia Daniel Chalef from
Graffiti and Zepai and Alex Gilmore from
Neo4j. Um the
the plan looks like this. I will do a
very quick power talk and about about
the topic that I'm super passionate
um the AI memory. Next we'll have four
live demos uh and we'll move on to some
new solution that we are proposing a
graph chat arena uh that I will be able
to demonstrate and I would like you to
follow along once it's being um
demonstrated and at the very end I will
have a very short Q&A session. Um
there is um a Slack channel that I would
like you to join. Um so please scan the
QR code right now before we begin and
let's make sure that everyone has access
to the um to these materials. There is
um a walk through short on the channel
that will go through
closer to the end of our workshop. But I
would like you to start setting it up if
you if you may on your laptops if you
want to follow along.
All right, it's a workshop graph chat.
You can also find it on Slack and you
can uh join the channel. So a little bit
about myself. Uh so hi everyone again.
I'm Mark Bane and I'm very passionate
about the memory. What is memory? The
deep physics and applications of memory
across different technologies.
Um you can find me at MarkBane uh on
social media or on my website. And let
me tell you a little bit of a story
about myself. Uh so when I was um 16
years old I was very good at maths and I
did math olympiads with many brilliant
minds including Voych Sara the
co-founder of open AI and thanks to that
deep understanding of math and physics I
did have many great opportunities to be
exposed to the problem of AI memory. So
first of all, I would like to recall um
two conversations that I had with Voych
and Ilia in 2014
in September when I came here to study
at Stanford. Um, at one party we met
with Ilia and Voytech who back then
worked at Google and they were kind of
trying to pitch me that there will be a
huge revolution in AI and I kind of like
followed that. I was a little bit
unimpressed back then. right now I
probably um
kind of take it as a very big excitement
when I look back to the times and I was
really wishing good luck to to the guys
who were doing deep learning because
back then I I didn't really see this
prospect of GPUs giving that huge edge
uh in compute.
Uh however uh during that conversation
it was like 20 minutes at the very end I
asked Ilia
all right so there is going to be a big
AI revolution
but how will these AI systems
communicate with each other
and the answer was very perplexing and
kind of sets the stage to what's
happening right now uh Ilia simply
answered I don't know I think they will
invent their own language.
So that was 11 years ago. Fast forward
to now. Um the last two years I've spent
doing very deep research on physics of
AI and kind of like dove into all of
these most modern AI architectures
including attention diffusion models,
VAEs and many other ones. And I realized
that there is something critical,
something missing.
And this power talk is about this
missing thing.
So over the last two years
I kind of followed on on my last years
of doing a lot of research in physics,
computer science, information science
and I came to this conclusion that
memory
AI memory in fact is any data in any
format and this is important including
code algorithms
and hardware. were
and any causal changes that affect them.
That was something very mind-blowing to
to reach that conclusion. And that
conclusion sets the tone to this whole
track, the graph track.
In fact, I was also perplexed by how
biological systems use memory and how
different cosmological structures or
quantum structures they in fact have a
memory. They kind of remember
and
let's get back to maths and to physics
and geometry. When I was doing science
olympiads, I was really focused on two
three things. Geometry, trigonometry and
algebra. And I realized
in the last year
that more or less the volume of
loss in physics perfectly matches the
volume of loss in mathematics. And also
the constants in mathematics, if you
really think deeply through geometry,
they match the constants
both in mathematics and in physics. And
if you really think even deeper, they
kind of like transcend over the all the
other disciplines.
So that made me think a lot. And I found
out
that the principles that govern LLMs
are the exact same principles that
govern neuroscience
and they are the exact same principles
that govern mathematics. I studied
I studied papers of
Perilman. I don't know if you've heard
who is Pearlman. Perilman is this
mathematician who refused
um to take a $1 million award for
proving the
um for for proving the one of the mo
most important conjectures
about symmetries of three spheres.
Um,
and once I realized that this deep math
of
spheres and circles is very much linked
with how attention and diffusion models
work. Basically the formulas that
Perilman reached are linking
entropy with curvature and curvature
basically if you think of curvature it's
attention it's gravity so in a sense
there are multiple disciplines where the
same things are appearing multiple times
and I will be publishing a series of
papers with some amazing
supervisors
who are
co-authors of two of these
uh meth methods methodologies
um the transformers and VAEs
and I came to this realization that this
equation governs everything governs mass
governs physics governs our AI memory
governs neuroscience biology physics
chemistry and so on and so forth.
So
I came to this equation that memory
times compute would like to be a squared
imaginary unit circle.
If that existed ever, we would have
perfect symmetries and we would kind of
not exist because for us to exist, this
asymmetries needs to show up. And in a
sense, every single LLM through weights
and biases, the weights are giving the
structure. The compute that comes and
transforms the data instead of the row
format. The compute turns it into
weights. The weights are basically if
you take these billions of parameters,
the weights are the sort of like matrix
structure of how this data looks like uh
when when you really find relationships
in the raw data. All right. And then
there are these biases, these tiny
shifts that are kind of like trying to
like in a robust way adapt to this model
so that it doesn't break apart but still
is still is very well reflecting the
reality. So something is missing. So
when we take weights and biases and we
apply scaling laws and we keep adding
more data, more compute, we kind of get
a better and better and better
understanding of the reality. In a
sense, if we had infinite data, we
wouldn't have any biases. And this
understanding
is again the principle of this track of
graph.
The disappearance of biases is what we
are looking for when we are scaling our
models.
So in a sense, the amount of memory and
compute should be exactly the same. it's
just slightly expressed in a different
way. But if there are some there are in
any imbalances
then something important happens.
And I came to another conclusion that
our universe is basically a network
database.
It has a graph structure and it's a
temporal structure. So it keeps on
moving following some certain principles
and rules.
And these principles and rules
are not necessarily fuzzy.
They have to be fuzzy
because otherwise everything would be
completely predictable.
But if it would be completely
predictable, it means that me myself
would know everything about every single
of you about myself from the past and
myself from the future. So in a sense
it's impossible and that's why we have
this sort of like heat diffusion entropy
models.
They allow us to exist but something is
preserved
relationships.
Any single asymmetry that happens at the
quantum level
any single tiny asymmetry that happens
preserves causal links
and these causal links are the exact
thing that I would like you to have as a
takeaway from this workshop.
The difference between simple rack,
hybrid rack, any types of rack and graph
rack is that we are having the ability
to keep these causal links in our memory
systems. Basically the relationships are
what preserves causality. That's why
we can solve hallucinations.
That's why we can optimize
hypothesis generation and testing.
So we will be able to do amazing
research in biosciences, chemical
sciences
just because of understanding that this
causality is preserved within the
relationships and these relationships
when there are these asymmetries that
are needed they kind of create this
curvature I would say. So we under we
intuitively feel every single of you is
choosing some specific workshops and
talks that you guys go to.
Right now all of you are attending to
the talk and workshop that we are
giving. It means that it matters to you
and it means that potentially you see
value and this value this information is
transcended through space and time.
It's very subjective to you or any other
object
and
I think we really
need to understand this.
So LMS are basically these weights and
biases or correlations. They give us
this opportunity to be fuzzy.
You know, actually one thing that I
learned from Voytech 10, 8, 11 years ago
was that hallucinations are the exact
necessary thing to be able to solve a
problem where you have too little memory
or too little compute for the
combinatorial space of the problem you
are solving. So you're basically
imagining you're taking some hypothesis
basing based on your history and you're
kind of trying to project it into the
future. But you have too little memory,
too little compute to do that. So you
can be as good as the amount of memory
and compute you have. So it means that
the missing part is something that you
kind of can curve thanks to all of these
causal relationships and this fuzziness.
and oops
reasoning
is reading of these asymmetries
and the causal links.
Hence,
I really believe that agentic systems
are
sort of the next big thing right now
because they are following the network
database principle.
But to be causal,
to recover this causality from our
fuzziness,
we need graph databases. We need causal
relationships. And that's the major
thing
in this emerging trend of graph
that we are here to talk about. And
I would like to at this moment invite on
stage our three amazing guest speakers.
And I would like to start with Vasilia.
Vasilia, please come over to to the
stage. Next will be Alex
and Daniel.
and I'll present something myself. All
right. So, uh, Vasilia will show us how
to lurch, search, and optimize memory
based on certain use case at hand. All
right,
let's test. Um,
so let's just make sure this works.
Okay. So, um,
nice to meet you all. Uh, and I'm
Vasili. I'm originally from Montenegro,
small country in the Balkans. Um,
beautiful. So, if you want to go there,
my cousins Igor and Milos are going to
welcome you. Everyone knows everyone. So
uh you know if in case you're just
curious about memory I'm building a
memory tool on top of the graph and
vector databases. My background is in
business big data engineering and
clinical psychology. So a lot what Mark
uh talked about kind of connects to
that. Um I'm going to show you a small
demo here. Uh the demo is to do a
Mexican standoff between two developers
where we are analyzing their GitHub
repositories and these uh data from the
GitHub repositories is in the graph and
this Mexican standoff means that we will
let the crew of agents go analyze look
at their data and try to compare them
against each other and give us a result
that should represent how uh who should
we hire let's say ideally out of these
two people. So uh what we're seeing here
currently is how Cognify works in the
background. So Cognify is working by uh
adding some data turning that into a
semantic graph and then we can search it
with wide variety of options. We plugged
in crew AI on top of it. So we can
pretty much do this on the fly. So um
here in the background I have a client
running. This client is connected to the
to the system. So um it's now currently
uh searching the data sets and uh
starting to build the graphs. So let's
uh see it takes a couple of seconds but
uh in the background uh we are
effectively ingesting the GitHub uh data
from the GitHub API building the
semantic structure and then uh letting
the agents actually search it and make
decisions on top of it. So as every time
with live demos things might go wrong.
So I have a video version in case this
does. Let's see
and I'll switch to the vid. Oh, here we
go. So uh the semantic graph started
generating and as you can see we have
activity log where the graph is being
continuously updated on the fly data is
being stored in memory and then uh data
is being enriched and the agents are
going and making decisions on top. So
what you can see here on the side is
effectively
the agentic logic that is reading,
writing, analyzing and using all of
these uh let's say preconfigured set of
weights and benchmarks to to analyze any
person here. So Cogni is a framework
that's modular. You can build this task.
You can ingest from any type of a data
source. 30 plus data sources supported
now. You can build any type of a custom
graph. You can build graph from
relational databases. Semi-structured
data. And we also have this memory
association layers inspired by the
cognitive science approach. And then
effectively um as we kind of build and
and enrich this graph on the fly, we see
that uh you know it's getting bigger,
it's getting more popular and then we're
storing the data back into the graph. So
this is the uh stateful temporal aspect
of it. We can build the graph in a way
that we can add the data back that we
can analyze these reports that we can
search them and that we can let other
agents access them on the fly. The idea
for us was let's have a place where
agents can write and continuously add
the data in. So um I'll have a look at
the graph now so we can inspect it a
bit. So if we click on on any note we
can uh see that uh the details about the
commits about the information from the
from the developers the PRs whatever
they did in the past and and which repos
they contributed to and then at the end
as the graph is pretty much filled we
would see the final report kind of
starting to come in. So let's see how
far we got with this. So it's taking
it's preparing now the final output for
the hiring decision task. So let's have
a look at that when it gets loaded.
We just finished this this morning. I
hope to had a hosted version for you all
today, but didn't work through AI's uh
causing some troubles. So uh let's uh we
had to resolve this one.
So let's see.
Yes. So I will just
show you the video with the end so we
don't wait for it.
So here you can see that towards the end
uh we can see the graph
and
we can see the final decision which is a
green node and in the green node we can
see that we decided to hire lasslo our
uh developer who has a PhD in graphs so
it's not really difficult to make that
call and we see why and we see the the
numbers and the benchmarks so thank you
this has been very past three minute
demo. So, hope you enjoyed and if you
have some questions, I'm here
afterwards. We we are open source, so
happy to see new users and if you're
interested, try it. Thanks. Woohoo.
Thank you. Thank you, Vasilia. Um, next
up is Alex. So, Vasilia showed us
something I call semantic memory. So,
basically, you take your raw data, you
load it, and cognify it, as they like to
say. Come on. Come on up, Alex. And
that's the base. That's something we
already are doing. And next up is Alex
who will show us Neo4j MCP uh server.
The stage is yours.
Test test. Five, four, three, two, one.
Good. Okay.
All right.
Okay. So, hi everyone. My name is Alex.
Um, I'm an AI architect at Neo Forj. Um,
and I'm going to demo the memory MCP
server that we have available. Um, so
there is this walkthrough document that
I have. Um, we'll make this available in
the Slack or by some means so that you
can do this on your own. Um, but it's
pretty simple to set up. Um and what
we're going to showcase today is really
like the foundational functionality that
we would like to see in a aentic memory
sort of application. Um primarily we're
going to take a look at semantic memory
in this um MCP server but we are
currently developing it and we're going
to add additional memory types as well
um which we'll discuss uh probably later
on in the presentation.
Um so in order to do this we will need a
neo forj database. Neo forj is a graph
native database that we'll be using to
store our knowledge graph that we're
creating. Um they have a aura option
which is um hosted in the cloud or we
can just do this locally with the neo
forj desktop app. Um additionally we're
going to do this via claw desktop and so
we just need to download that and then
we can just add this config to the um
mcp configuration file in claude and
this will just connect to the neo forj
instance that you create. Um, and what's
happening here is we're going to uh
Claude will pull down um the memory
server from Pi and it'll host it in the
back end for us. And then it'll be able
to use the tools that are accessible via
the MCP server.
And the final thing that we're going to
do before we can actually have the
conversation is we're just going to use
this brief system prompt. And what this
does is just ensure that we are properly
recalling and then logging memories
after each interaction that we have.
Uh so with that um we can take a look at
a conversation that I had um in claw
desktop using this memory server. Um and
so this is a conversation about starting
an agentic AI memory company. Um and so
we can see um all these tool calls here.
And so initially we have nothing in our
memory store which is as expected. But
as we kind of progress through this
conversation, we can see that at each
interaction, it tries to recall memories
that are related to the user prompt. And
then at the end of this interaction, it
will create new entities in our
knowledge graph um and relationships.
And so in this case, an entity is going
to have a name, a type, and then a list
of observations. And these are just
facts that we know about this entity.
And this is what is going to be updated
um as we learn more
in terms of the relationships. These are
just identifying how these rel uh how
these entities relate to one another.
And this is really the core piece of why
using a uh graph database as sort of the
context layer here is so important
because we can we can identify how these
um entities are actually related to each
other. It provides a very rich context.
And so as this goes on, we can see that
we have quite a few interactions. We are
adding observations, creating more
entities.
And at the very end here, we can see we
have quite a lengthy conversation. We
can say, you know, let's review what we
have so far. And so we can read the
entire knowledge graph back as context.
And Claude can then summarize that for
us. And so we have all the entities we
found, all the relationships that we've
identified, and all the facts that we
know about these entities based on our
conversation. And so this provides a
nice review of what we've discussed
about this company and our ideas about
how to create it. Now we can also go
into Neoraj browser um and this is
available both in aura and local and we
can actually visualize this knowledge
graph. We can see that we discussed Neo
forj we discussed MCP and langraph and
if we click on one of these nodes we can
see that there is a list of observations
that we have and this is all the
information that we've tracked
throughout that conversation. And so
it's important to know that like even
though this knowledge graph was created
with this single conversation, we can
also take this and use it in additional
conversations, we can use this knowledge
graph with other um uh clients such as
cursor IDE or windsurf. And so this is
really a powerful way to um create a
like memory layer for all of your
applications.
Um and so with that, um I'll pass it on.
Thank you. All right, give a round of
applause to Alex.
Thank you, Alex. The next up is Daniel.
Um, I will just share personal um
beliefs about MCPS. Um, I was testing
MCPS of Neo4j, Graffiti, Cogni, Mezier
just before the workshop and I'm a
strong believer that this is our future.
We'll have to work on that. And in a
second I will be showing a mini graph
chat arena. And next up something very
very important that Daniel does is
temporal graphs. Daniel uh is co-founder
of graffiti and zep. They have 10,000
stars on GitHub and growing very fast.
The stage is yours. Daniel, please show
us what you do. Thank you. So five,
four, three, two, one. Did that work?
seems to have. Right? So, um
I'm here today to tell you that there's
no onesizefits all memory. Um
and why you need to model your memory
after your business domain. So, if you
saw me a little bit earlier and I was
talking about Graffiti, Zep's
open-source temporal graph framework,
um, you might have seen me just speak to
how you can build custom entities and
edges in the graffiti graph for your
particular business domain. So, business
objects from your business domain. What
I'm going to demo today is actually how
Zep implements that and how it easy it
is to use from Python, TypeScript or Go.
And what we've done here is we've solved
a fundamental problem plaguing memory.
And we're enabling developers to
build out memory that is far more cogent
and capable for many different use
cases. So I'm going to just show you a
quick example of
where things go really wrong. So many of
you might have used chat GPT before. It
generates facts about you in memory. And
you might have noticed that it really
struggles with relevance.
Sometimes it just pulls out all sorts of
arbitrary facts about you. And
unfortunately when you store arbitrary
facts and retrieve them as memory, you
get inaccurate responses or
hallucinations.
And the same problem happens when you're
building your own agents.
So here we go. We have an example media
assistant and it should remember things
about jazz music, MPR, podcasts, the
daily, etc. All the things that I like
to listen to, but unfortunately because
I'm in conversation with the agent or
it's picking up my voice when I'm, you
know, it's a voice agent, um, it's
learning all sorts of irrelevant things
like I wake up at 7 am. my dog's name is
Melody, etc. And the point here is that
irrelevant facts pollute memory. They're
not specific to the media player
business domain. And so the technical
reality here is as well that many
frameworks take this really simplistic
approach approach to generating facts.
If you're using a framework that has
memory capabilities, agent framework,
it's generating facts and throwing it
into a vector database. And
unfortunately, the facts dumped into the
vector database or reddus mean that when
you're recalling that memory, it's
difficult to differentiate what should
be returned. We're going to return what
is semantically similar. And here we
have um a bunch of facts that are
semantically similar to my request for
my favorite tunes. Um, we have some good
things and unfortunately Melody is there
as well because Melody is a dog named
Melody and that might be something to do
with tunes. Um, and
so
bunch of irrelevant stuff.
So basically semantic similarity is not
business relevance
and this is not unexpected.
I was speaking a little bit earlier
about how vectors in are just basically
projections into an embedding space.
There's no causal or relational uh
relations between them. And so we need a
solution. We need domain aware memory,
not better semantic search.
So, with that, I am going to
unfortunately be showing you a video
because the Wi-Fi has been absolutely
terrible. Um,
and let me bring up the video.
Okay.
So,
I built a little application here and it
is a finance coach and I've told it I
want to buy a house.
And it's asking me, well, how much do I
earn a year? It's asking me about what
student loan debt I might have. And
we'll see that on the right hand side,
what is stored in Zep's memory
are some very explicit
business objects. We have financial
goals, debts, income sources, etc. These
are defined by the developer and they're
defined in a way which is really simple
to understand. We can use paidantic or
zod or go strcts
and we can apply business rules. So
let's go take a look at some of the code
here. We have a TypeScript financial
goal schema using Zep's underlying SDK.
We can define these entity types. We can
give a description to the entity type.
Uh we can even define fields, the
business rules for those fields. So the
values that they take on. And then we
can build tools for our agent to
retrieve a financial snapshot which runs
multiple zep searches at the same time
concurrently and filters by specific
node types.
And when we start our Zep application,
what we're going to do is we're going to
register these particular goals uh sorry
objects with uh Zep. So it knows to
build this ontology in the graph. So
let's do a quick little addition here.
I'm going to say that I have $5,000
month rent.
I think it's rent.
And in a few seconds, we see that Zep's
already paused that new message and has
captured that $5,000. And we can go look
at the chart, the graph. This is the the
Zep front end. And we can see the
knowledge graph for this user has got a
debt account entity. It's got fields on
it um that we've defined as a developer.
And so again, we can really get really
tight about what we retrieve from Zep by
filtering. Okay, so we're at time. So
just very quickly, we wrote a paper
about how this all of this works. You
can get to it uh by that link below. And
appreciate your time today.
You can look me up afterwards.
Great paper, by the way.
All right. Uh once I'm getting ready um
I would appreciate if you confirm with
me uh whether you have access to Slack.
Uh is the Slack working for you the
Slack channel. All right. I think we are
slowly running out of time. So I'd
appreciate if you have any questions to
any of the speakers. Please uh write
these questions on Slack and we will be
outside of this room and we are happy to
answer more of these questions just
after the workshop.
I right now move on with um a use case
that I developed and to this graph rack
uh chat arena
to be specific
before
delving into agentic memory into
knowledge graphs.
I led a private cyber security lab
and worked for defense clients, a very
big clients with very serious problems
on the security side. And I used to
in one project I had to navigate between
something like 27 29 different terminals
and shells
and
it requires knowing lots of languages
like if you think of like different
Linux distros every firewall and
networking devices usually has its own
shell proprietary often there is
PowerShell so you need to know like lots
of languages to communicate with these
machines to to work with such clients
and I realized that LLMs are not only
amazing to translate these languages but
they are also very good to kind of
create a new type of shell a human
language shell. There are such shells
but such shells they would really be
excellent if they have episodic memory
the sort of temporal memory of what was
happening in this shell historically.
And if we have access to this temporal
history, the events, we kind of know
what the users were doing, what their
behaviors are, we kind of can control
every single code execution function
that's running, including the ones of
agents. So I spotted with some investors
and advisers of mine, I spotted a niche,
something we call agentic firewall, and
I wanted to do a super quick demo of how
it would work.
So basically you would um run commands
and type pwd and in a sense we I suppose
lots of us had computer science classes
or or we worked in shell and we have to
remember all of these commands like um
show me running docker containers like
it's docker ps right but if you go for
more advanced commands we can
Uh, I think it's for a reason. Yeah, I
think it's for a reason. Um,
one second.
Sorry about that.
All right, it's there. Okay, thank you.
In general, I would need to know right
now some command that can extract me,
for instance, the name of the container
that's running and its status. Show me
just
um image and status.
I can make mistakes like human language
fuzzy mistakes. Um
show if Apache is running.
All right, show the command
we did three
commands ago.
So basically, if you plug in the
agentic,
if you plug in the agentic memory to
things like that, I think I think it got
it wrong, but you get me right. So if I
get through like different shells and
terminals
um and I have this textual context that
what was done and the context of the
certain machine of what is happening
here
and it kind of spans across all the user
all the machines all the users and all
the sessions in PTY TTY I think that we
can really have a very good context also
for security so that space um the
temporal locks, the episodic locks is
something that I see will boom and
emerge. So I believe that all of our
agents that will be executing code in
terminals will be executing it through a
maybe not all but the ones that are
running uh on the enterprise gate they
will be going through agentic firewalls.
I'm I'm close to sure about that. So
that's my use case. Um, and now let's
move on to GraphRack Chat Arena. So, you
have on Slack
uh a link to this doc and this doc is
allowing you to set up a repo that we've
created for this workshop and we'll be
promoting it afterwards. So about a year
ago I met with Jeru from Namal Index and
we were chatting quite a while about
like how to evolve this conversational
memory and he gave me two pieces of
advice. One of them think about data
abstractions the other think about
evolves.
Data abstractions I kind of quickly
solve within like two months. Evils I
realized that there won't be any evolves
in form of a benchmark. This all of
these hot potatoes and all of that it's
fun. I know that there are great papers
written by our guest speakers and other
folks about hot potatoes, but it's not
the thing. You can't do a benchmark for
a thing that doesn't exist. Basically,
the agentic graph memory will be this
type of memory that evolves. So, you
don't know what will evolve. So, if you
don't know what will evolve, you will
need a simulation arena and that will be
the only right
evil.
So one year fast forward and we've
created a prototype of such a gentic
memory arena. Think about it like web
arena but for memory. And let me quickly
show you that you can go to this
repository. I did a fork of that there
is mezzero, there is graffiti, there is
cogni um and there will be two
approaches. one approach will be um
sort of the repo the the library itself
and the other is through MCPS because we
don't really know what will work out
better so whether repos or the MCPS will
work out better so we'll need to test
these different approaches but we need
to create this arena for that so you
basically clone that repo and we use ADK
for that so we get this nice chat where
you can talk to these agents
And you can switch between agents. So I
want to talk with Neo and there is a
Neo4j agent running behind the scenes.
There is a cipher graph agent running
behind the scenes and I can kind of for
now switch between these agents. Maybe
I'll increase the phone size a little
bit. So the Neo agents basically
answering the questions about this
amazing technology, the graphs,
specifically Neo forj.
and I can switch to cipher
and then an agent that is excellent at
running cipher queries talks with me and
I'm writing add to graph data mark and
I'm passionate about memory
architectures and basically what it does
is it runs these layers that are created
by cogni by mezero by graffiti and all
the other vendors of semantic and
temporal memory solutions
or specifically created by an MCP server
that Alex was demonstrating, the Neo
Forj MCP server. So, I'm really looking
forward to how this uh technology
evolves. But what I really what I
quickly wanted to show you is that it
already works. It has this science of
being this identic memory arena. So I
can ask my graph through questions and
the agent goes to the connection. This
is just one. You know what's amazing?
It's just one Neo4j graph.
It's just one Neo4j graph on the back
end and all of these technologies that
can be tested how the graphs are being
created and retrieved. It's it's like
when I think of that it's like the most
brilliant idea that we can do with
agentic memory simulations. So I get
answers from the graph. Here is the
graph. I can basically rerun uh the
commands to see what's happening on this
graph. And let me just move on
and next thing is I would like to add to
the graph that Vasilio will show how to
integrate Cognney and So I add new
information and the cipher writes it to
the graph
and then I want to do something else.
It's it's super early stage still but
then I transfer to graffiti and I can
repeat the exact same process. So I can
right now using graffiti search what I
just added and I can switch between
these different memory solutions. So
that's why I'm so excited about that.
And we do not have time to like practice
it together, do the workshop, but I'm
sure we will write some articles. So
please follow us. And I would appreciate
if you have any questions, pass them on
to Slack. I I will ask Andreas whether
we have time for a short Q&A or we need
to move it to to like breakout or
outside of the room. Take like five
minutes. Five minutes. All right. So um
that's all for for now for today. I I
really uh would like um Vasilia, Daniel
and Alex to come back to stage so you
can ask any of us. Please uh direct the
questions to to any of us and we'll try
to uh answer them. Yeah, let's go. Hi,
I'm Lucas. Um I want to ask a a
fundamental question. How do you decide
what is a bad memory over time? uh
because you you could like as a
developer and as a person we evolve the
the line of thought right so one thing
that you thought was good like 3 years
10 years ago may not be good right today
uh so how do you decide
a very good question so um I I'll answer
in maybe you guys can help I will answer
in a very scientific way so basically
the one that causes a lot of noise the
noisy one doesn't make a lot of sense
So you decrease noise by redundancy
and by relationships. So the less
relationships and the more noisiness
the so in a sense and not not well
connected node has a potential of not
being correct but there are other ways
to validate that and would you like to
follow on? Yeah, sure. Uh, a practical
way, um, we we let you model the data
with Pantics. So, you can kind of blow
the data you need and add weights, uh,
to the edges and nodes. So, you can do
something like temporal waiting. You can
add your custom let's say logic and then
effectively you would know how your data
is kind of evolving in in time and and
how it's becoming less or more relevant
and what is the set of algorithms you
would need to apply. So, this is the
idea not solve it for you but let help
you solve it with tooling. Um but yeah
there is depends on the use case I would
say. Yeah I don't think I think that's a
great explanation. I I think I what I
would add is that there is missing
causal causal links. Missing causal
links is what is most probably
a good indicator of fuzziness. Yeah.
Next question.
Can you hear me? How would you bet embed
in um security or privacy into the
network or the application layer? If
there's a corporate, they have top
secret data or I have personal data that
in the graph I want to share that but
not all of it.
Oh, that's a that's a really good one. I
I think I'll answer that um very
briefly. So, basically you do have to
have that context. You do have to have
that these decisions intentions of
colonels of majors and anyone like in
the enterp like seesaw and anyone's in
in the enterprise stack and in a sense
it also gets kind of like fuzzy and
complex. So I expect this to be a very
big challenge that's that's why I want
to work in that. But I'm sure that
applying ontologies, the right
ontologies first of all to this
enterprise cyber security stack really
kind of provides this guard guard rails
for navigating this challenging problem
and and decreasing this fuzziness and
errors. Thank you. Yeah, I would also
just add like all these applications are
built on Neo forj and so in Neo forj you
can like do RO based access controls and
so you can prevent users from accessing
data that they're not allowed to see. So
it's something that you can configure
with that.
This question is for Mark.
Yeah, go on. Go on. Go on. You were
about to say something. Please go ahead.
Just one thing like we also noticed that
if you isolate per graph per user or
kind of keep it like very physically
separate for us it works really works
well people react to that really well so
that's one way yes independent graphs
personal graphs yeah Mark in your
earlier presentation you mentioned and
this equation that related gravity
entropy and something and also memory
and compute to I square could you show
those two again and explain them again
of course yeah if if we have time other
than that um It's probably for a series
of papers to properly explain that. So
that's one memory times compute equals I
square. The other one is that if you
take all the attention diffusion and VAS
which are doing the smoothing, it
preserves the sort of asymmetries.
So very briefly speaking, let's set up
the vocabulary. So first of all,
curvature equals attention equals
gravity. This is the very simple most
important principle here. I I will need
to when writing these papers we are
really tightly trying to define these
three next diffusion heat entropy
it's the exact same thing we just need
to align definitions and if it's not
exact same thing if there are other
definitions we need to show what's
really different and now if you think
about attention
it kind of shows the sort of like
pathways towards certain asymmetries if
you take a sphere if you start bending
that sphere and make it like you know
like you you kind of try to extend it,
two things happen. Entropy increases and
curvature increases in a sense and and
perman what he did he proved that you
can like bend these spheres in any way
3D spheres 4D and 5D and higher like
level spheres were already solved. So he
solved for 3D sphere and these equations
are proving that basically there won't
be any other architectures for LMS. it
will be just attention diffusion models
and VAS like maybe not just VAS but like
kind of like something that moves uh
leaves room for biases.
All right, thank you all. Uh I really
appreciate you coming. I hope it was
helpful. Thank you the guest speakers
and we'll answer the questions uh
outside of the room. Appreciate that.